[Musik]
sebastian verrät den trick hinter den
völkern ehlen perfekt das klebt wir
zeigen wie einfach man kunden mit surimi
hinters licht führen kann
surimi kennen wir alle aus dem
supermarkt sieht irgendwie witzig aus
oder aus dem japanischen übersetzt heißt
surimi zermahlen das fleisch nur welches
gleich so remy besteht aus fisch der auf
anderem wege nicht mehr vermarktet
werden kann und damit der zu surimi wird
muss ich ihnen erst mal in seine
einzelteile zerlegen eine idee ganz nach
dem geschmack der lebensmittel industrie
ganz in weiß mit einem tablett voll
fisch surimi gibt es seit jahrhunderten
in japan ist es eine traditionelle
spezialität damit wir an das pure fisch
fleisch kommen müssen wir jetzt erstmal
alles group separieren deswegen achtung
es wird jetzt schmutzig
das filetieren von hand wird über so
kleinen fischen viel zu lange dauern und
wäre auch viel zu teuer
hiermit geht es wesentlich schneller was
sebastian läge hier macht geschieht
normalerweise noch auf hoher see direkt
auf den fang schiffen die fische werden
ausgenommen und dann mit wasserdruck in
ihre bestandteile zerlegt
super funktioniert und wie man sehen
kann bleiben nur noch die gräten übrig
das fleisch der fische verwandelt sich
in eine wässrige masse die sebastian
läge nach und nach reinigt klein
gerieben wird daraus ein nahezu
geschmacksneutral fischbrei der lässt
sich in jede beliebige form bringen
[Musik]
super feinstes fisch muskel eiweiß so
nennt man das auf der zutatenliste bei
so really perfekt das klebt
[Gelächter]
damit das zu so viel geld brauchte es
noch einige bindemittel phosphat und
modifizierte stärke sollen den fischbrei
später in form halten
doch für den perfekten fake reicht das
noch nicht dass er weiß was im versteck
reicht nicht aus um diesen bis zu
erzeugen um eine garnele oder einen
krebs tick zu simulieren
deswegen kommt der hühner eiweißpulver
rein hühnereiweiß im märz früchte salat
auf diese idee kommt nur die
lebensmittelindustrie und jetzt können
sie sich entscheiden was möchten sie
kanäle oder krebs
ich nehme die garnele mit aroma aus dem
labor ist der typische meeresfrüchte
geschmack in sekunden hergestellt
jetzt kann sebastian läge in ruhe an der
optik arbeiten
[Musik]
das sieht so gut aus
er spritzt den brei in formen aus
silikon
das kommt hier auf deckel drauf und
jetzt kriegen die kleinen babys ein
bisschen dampf und beim garen im dampf
stocken die hitzeempfindlichen eiweiße
und die bindemittel entfalten ihre kraft
so entsteht die typische garnelen artige
konsistenz
[Musik]
nur noch vorsichtig aus der form lösen
[Gelächter]
diese blassen würmer gehen so noch nicht
als kanäle durch was fehlt ist eine
ordentliche portion farbe so jungs jetzt
geht's mal richtig lag hier
wie sagt man doch so schön das auge isst
mit
die produktion von nachgemachten
garnelen aus surimi ist ziemlich
aufwendig dafür sind die verwendeten
zutaten extrem günstig im großen maßstab
hergestellt lohnt sich der aufwand für
die industrie vor allem wenn die kunst
produkte als echte garnelen durchgehen
das ist ja klar dass man hier schon
sieht dass das keine echte garnele ist
aber wie sieht das denn so meeresfrüchte
salat aus ich behaupte dass mac einer in
düsseldorf will sebastian lege den
beweis antreten
zwei meeresfrüchte cocktails hat er im
angebot einmal mit echter kanäle und
einmal mit geschickter surimi kamele mag
sie meeresfrüchte ja gerne
[Musik]
es geht los
legt einfach schon mal los die können
schon mal probieren und dann sagte mir
was ihr schmeckt was ihr seht was ihr
fühlt wer fällt auf die falsche kanäle
rein was einem schmeckt eigentlich mehr
mehr gewürze sind andrea okay
ansonsten schmeckt sie keinen
unterschied ob ich wirklich okay
also das sieht aus wie teile von shrimps
okay ist aber alles strömte die hänge
sind die für mich die großen gamba das
ist für mich das könnte sein
im direkten vergleich kommen früher oder
später alle tester darauf dass sebastian
läge in einer schüssel i kanälen
serviert hat fish fry nachgebaute
meeresfrüchte können geschmacklich also
nicht mit echten mithalten trotzdem
werden sie produziert und vor allem an
kunden in der gastronomie verkauft die
dürfen sie natürlich nicht als echte
garnelen anbieten
doch stichproben der
lebensmittelaufsicht baden württemberg
zeigen die restaurants schummeln von 18
getesteten betrieben haben neun ihren
kunden zur emi als echte meeresfrüchte
serviert
vorsicht auch vor meeresfrüchte
mischungen aus dem supermarkt
in diesem klima royal steckt tatsächlich
fischbrei und hühnereiweiß das mit
bindemitteln und phosphat gestreckt und
mit farbstoff angemalt wurde
wahrscheinlich sind die vorschriften für
die deklaration auf den märkten oder
auch in der gastronomie nicht
ausreichend denn ich muss nicht sofort
beim namen des produktes schon sehen
können ist das remis drin oder nicht
ich erkenne es meistens nicht so richtig
ist es oft versteckt angegeben wenn
überhaupt und von daher könnte hier noch
deutlich nachgebessert werden um den
verbrauchern auch wirklich die volle
transparenz zu geben falsche
meeresfrüchte gibt es häufiger als
gedacht
die verlockung ist groß kunden damit
hinters licht zu führen
doch das muss nicht sein nachhaltige
garnelen aus der region könnte es bald
überall geben
unsere reise zu nachhaltig produzierten
garnelen führt und nach bayern in eine
kleine gemeinde im umland von münchen in
dieser unscheinbaren gewerbehalle
befindet sich eine anlage die für die
zukunft der garnelen zucht
richtungsweisend sein sollten
die indoor aquakultur von langenpreising
1,5 millionen bayern garnelen züchtet
das start-up jährlich
in acht becken wachsen die tiere bis zur
vollen größe heran
[Musik]
hier sieht man jetzt mal alle kanäle
er hat noch ein eiweiß schirm auf dem
panzer darauf dass ganz sauber und
wahnsinnig kräftig weil der ganze
hintere teil ist muskelmasse der
technische aufwand für die bayern
garnele ist riesig jedes der becken
enthält etwa so viel wasser wie ein
vierpersonenhaushalt pro jahr verbraucht
all dieses wasser muss permanent hin und
her gepumpt aufbereitet und geheizt
werden
all das kostet jede menge geld und
verschlingt enorm viel energie
[Musik]
nur bei der futterverwertung sind dann
ehlen wahre meister der effizienz
also wenn man gut ist dann schmeißt man
so ungefähr 1,3 kilo futter rein und
kriegt ein kilo kanäle raus 1,3 kilo
futter für ein kilo kanäle hühner und
schweine verbrauchen da deutlich mehr
bei rindern ist der futterbedarf im
vergleich zur garnele sogar zehnmal
höher garnelen statt rindfleisch
die eingesparten futtermengen sind im
globalen maßstab enorm
die garnelen im bayrischen
langenpreising wachsen unter künstlichen
bedingungen auf das startup versucht die
tiere durch digitale steuerung möglichst
schnell möglichst fit zu bekommen
in stahltanks bei kunstlicht ohne
frische luft und natürliche
sonneneinstrahlung kann das gut sein für
die umwelt tiere und klima
ursprünglich ist diese garnele in den
mangrovenwäldern südamerikas zu hause
das bedeutet ganzjährig sommer bei um
die 30 grad luft und 28 grad
wassertemperatur
auch die bayern garnele will es warm
haben heizkosten sind für die indoor
zucht der mit abstand größte posten
[Musik]
und auch die wasseraufbereitung
verschlingt jede menge energie als
mangroven bewohner brauchen garnelen
salzwasser zum leben
habt ihr salzgehalt schon gemessen oder
wollen wir das noch mal eben wir
brauchen wir noch mal ja ich gebe dir
das mal rein testen hier also zwei
prozent salzgehalt der vorteil den wir
hier haben in der geschlossenen farm ist
dass wir eben alle negativen einfluss im
grunde versuchen hier zu vermeiden die
bleiben vor der tür quasi und damit
haben wir eine zucht atmosphäre die
immer konstant bleiben bisher werden
garnelen in warmen ländern nahe dem
äquator gezüchtet dort findet die
garnelen zucht aber in offenen gewässern
statt ausscheidungen der tiere gelangen
in böden und flüsse gegen eingeschleppte
krankheiten werden medikamente
eingesetzt
folgen sind oft schwere umweltschäden
die zucht an land soll das verhindern
lang basierte zuchten sind grundsätzlich
auch sehr nachhaltig weil sie eben nicht
der umwelt zur last fallen weil wir im
geschlossenen system das wasser immer
wieder aufbereiten
kein einsatz von chemikalien wir haben
nur einen sehr geringen wasseraustausch
und wir müssen die garnelen nicht weit
transportieren sondern wir sind ja in
der region wo auch der konsum
stattfindet
derzeit produziert die anlage in
langenpreising etwa 30 tonnen garnelen
pro jahr
zum vergleich die aquakulturen in china
südostasien und amerika messen jährlich
3,5 millionen tonnen
doch der anfang ist gemacht erst wurden
spitzenköche aus der sterne gastronomie
auf die bayern garnele aufmerksam
jetzt liegt sie auch bundesweit in den
fischtheken gut sortierter supermärkte
die hier produzierte garnele kann
preislich noch nicht mithalten 59 euro
90 verlangen die deutschen züchter pro
kilo gegen etwa 18 euro bei
herkömmlicher produktion
doch der in der aquakultur gehört die
zukunft
davon sind die gründer überzeugt
genau das gleiche geht mit meeresfischen
es werden aktuell auch weltweit in
verschiedenen ländern in den usa in
europa in japan land basierte lachszucht
umgebaut oder auch andere arten von
fischen also das macht immer mehr schule
weil die sea food industrie natürlich
weiß dass wir nicht mehr für proteine
aus den meeren rausbekommen werden nur
mit bio futter und grüner energie kann
garnelen zucht auch bei uns in
deutschland eine gute sache sein
dann können garnelen in zukunft einen
wichtigen beitrag leisten die
weltbevölkerung auf nachhaltige weise
satt zu bekommen
denn kaum ein anderes tier verwertet das
eingesetzte futter so effektiv achtet
ihr beim fischkauf auf die herkunft sagt
es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr power essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips